[Music]
thank you very much indeed Hannah thank
you all for coming this is very exciting
now when it comes to parenting everyone
is an expert and we all have some skin
in the game so what I'm hoping tonight
is that because it's a debate we're
going to get an answer and that means
that we're gonna hear the four sweetest
words in the English language I told you
so
and never these words sweeter than when
they're uttered
between a parent and a child in one
direction or another
um I listen to this debate from an
extremely luxurious position because my
son lives with his mother and his
stepfather who are both superb parents
so I get to watch this on the sidelines
and think well if I know if it really
matters well that's all right they're
taking care of it for me not only that
but because I'm an identical twin he has
two biological fathers as well as his
lovely stepfather and as he frequently
reminds me if I ever get married he'll
have two mothers so he's gonna have five
parents so I really I'm pretty low in
the mix with all of this so I get to
enjoy it no matter the outcome the
motion is parenting doesn't matter or
not as much as you think so here's
what's happened you've already voted on
the motion shortly we're gonna hear the
opening remarks of our speakers and then
I'm going to announce the results of the
first vote and then there's going to be
some debate then we're going to take
your questions and you're going to vote
again now you have these voting cards
that are for and against and here's how
you vote if you're four you place the
four one in if you're against bless the
against one in and if you're not sure
you pitted put it in on taunt so on
taunt so throughout the evening as you
anxiously bend it back and forth and
worry it do not tear it in half because
then you're committed to making a
decision and you are allowed to be
undecided at the end of the evening okay
so we have four amazing speakers let me
talk you through our first speaker who
is in favor of the motion Robert Plomin
believes that parent
doesn't matter or not nearly as much as
you might think he is a psychologist and
a professor of behavioral genetics of
the Institute of Psychiatry psychology
and neuroscience at King's College
London and his new book blueprint how
DNA makes us who we are
argues that the most important thing our
parents give us is our genes and the
parenting styles don't really affect
children's outcomes Robert take it away
[Applause]
[Music]
when I was in graduate school 45 years
ago psychology was so dominated by
environmentalism the view that we are
what we learned that genetics it was a
dangerous to even mention genetics we
were told for example that schizophrenia
was caused by what your mother did to
you in the first few years of life in
the ensuing 44 decades a mountain of
evidence has accumulated that's
convinced most scientists of the
importance of inherited DNA differences
in shaping who we are as individuals
that message is getting pretty
well-known but what isn't quite as
well-known is the other part of the
message and that is these are the best
evidence we have for the importance of
the environment but the data show that
the way the environment works is very
different from the way environmentalists
thought it worked it's not due to
systemic in Vartan environmental
influence like parenting that we would
call nurture that the salient
environmental influences are essentially
idiosyncratic stochastic in a word
random so I'll try and convince you of
that in my remaining nine minutes but to
summarize it an easy way of remembering
it is that I'm saying that if you were
adopted at Birth you were reared by
different parents you grew up in a
different family you went to a different
school had different friends had a
different job you would essentially be
the same similar to who you are now and
that isn't just the thought experiment
Bobby went to what grew up in New York
and at 19 he went to upstate New York to
go to university on his first day on
campus people came up to Bobby calling
him Eddie and they seemed to know who he
was and he found out soon because he met
Eddie and it was he said it was like
looking in a mirror this other person
was very similar to him and then it
turned out they had both been adopted at
the same adoption agency in
city and the publicity that came from
this brought out a very rare case of an
identical triplet who is also extremely
similar and they're not just similar
physically they're also similar
psychologically they're all in
personality they're all outgoing their
interests are similar they're all
interested in acting and they're also
similar in terms of mental health and
illness they're all prone to depression
and so this remarkable story is being
told in a film that's coming out at the
end of this month in the UK it came out
in the States in the summer and it won
an award at Sundance for a documentary
film so it really is I would really
encourage people to see it because it's
a dramatic illustration of the
importance of genetics despite
differences in nurture one of these was
a beard in a lower-class family one in a
middle-class family and one in an
upper-class family and yet they're still
so remarkably similar but although it's
dramatic you don't need identical twins
reared apart to separate nature and
nurture
so Xand and his brother Chris as you
know are identical twins and they're
actually more different physically than
a lot of identical twins and is the
short chubby one he's he's a half-inch
shorter than his brother Chris and yeah
and six kilos and Counting heavier but
de grâce so although they're reared
together you can compare identical twins
to non identical twins one percent of
all births are twins one-third are
identical twins identical twins or
clones they have the same DNA non
identical twins like any brother and
sister are 50% similar genetically so
that method the twin method has been
used to study hundreds of psychological
traits and that's what I've done in my
study in the UK that I began when I came
to England in 1994 it's called the twins
early development study so we studied a
lot of aspects of childhood development
and we find like everyone else does that
about half of the differences we see in
kids psychological development including
educational achievement and mental
health and illness can be explained by
genetic differences the environment but
that means 50 percents environmental but
these environmental differences aren't
due to nurture they're not due to
systemic forces in the family that make
kids in a family similar whatever it is
it's making two kids in the same family
as different as kids and other families
and that includes identical twins a
method that is makes it easier to
understand that is the adoption method
so parents and offspring share nature
and nurture
but with adoption you can separate those
two you can study genetic parents who
share nature but not nurture these are
biological parents and they're adopted
away kids and you can study
environmental parents adoptive parents
who share nurture but not nature with
their children so for weight for example
you can predict the child's about 10
percent of the differences in children's
weight with their parents weight is that
nature or nurture with adopted children
you can't predict any variants any
differences between the kids weight from
their adoptive parents there's no
relationship between the adoptive
parents and the adopted children whereas
those adopted children are correlated as
much with their birth parents who they
never saw after the first year of life
as our children reared by their
biological parents suggesting the
importance of nature and not nurture so
I want to emphasize that we're talking
about differences why children differ in
personality and mental health and
illness and mental abilities and
disabilities and we're describing those
differences there's two caveats that are
very important we're describing what is
the genetic and environmental factors
that exist in a population at the time
we study it we're not talking about what
could be so weight you may be surprised
to know it's about 70% heritable that
means of the differences in weight in
this room about 70% of the differences
are due to inherited DNA differences
even if it was a hundred percent
heritable it doesn't mean you can't
change your weight if you stop eating
you lose weight so this is the
difference between what is and what
could be and its second caveat that I
think is very important in terms of the
other speakers is that we're talking
about the normal range of environmental
and genetic influences we're not talking
about the genetic extremes of rare
mutations that can have devastating
effects on the child nor are we talking
about the environmental extremes like
neglect and abuse so I know it's a lot
to take on board in ten minutes but the
first half of my book talks about all
these issues in detail so you know if
you want to get the evidence behind
these sorts of conclusions it is
available there in summary what the book
is trying to say is that inherited DNA
differences are the major systemic force
in shaping who we are the environment is
important but it's essentially random
it's not systemic effects of very family
variables like parenting and then
thirdly a third finding is we call the
nature of nurture
that a lot of what looks like systemic
environmental effects is actually
reflecting genetic differences so we
find that hundreds of studies have
looked at the correlation between
parenting aspects of parenting and
children's outcomes but you can't assume
that correlation is causal
environmentally because parents share
50% of their genes with their children
and furthermore we know that parents
respond to genetic differences in their
children unless you have a genetically
sensitive design you can't separate out
the effects of nature and nurture so
these three findings lead me to the
title of the book that DNA is the major
systemic source of individual
differences between us and when you
think about it in terms of parenting
I've done probably 20 interviews and the
phrase that gets most people's attention
is relevant to tonight and that is that
parents matter but they don't make a
difference so in although it's confusing
in terms of the title that you're voting
on I believe that parents matter a lot
they're the NASA / don't make a
difference in terms of the kids
psychological outcomes so I think of it
I think it's important we don't think of
parenting as a means to an end I think
that this is where I get on the soapbox
I think of parenting as a relationship
and just as with our relationship with
our partners and our friends I think our
relationship with our children should be
based on loving them rather than
changing them and instead of trying to
change children we can there's the
difference between what is and what
could be we can change them but instead
of always trying to change them and
molding them into what we want
to be doesn't it make sense to think
about going with the genetic flow and
find out what they like to do and what
they're good at and help them to do that
because if you love them you want what's
best for them and I hope this is the
liberating message for parents one that
relieves them of some of the anxiety and
guilt that is piled on parents by parent
blaming books that scare parents into
thinking one false move and their
child's going to be ruined forever so in
conclusion I I suggest that parents
relax and enjoy their relationship and
that part of this enjoyment comes from
watching our children become who they
are genetically thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Robert thank you very much indeed well
some of you may feel that that let you
off the hook a bit but others of you may
be wanting to feel useful and that you
can make a difference unfortunately for
you our next speaker is going to argue
against the motion
Susan Paul B is a developmental clinical
psychologist and a visiting senior
research fellow in the School of Life
Course Sciences at King's College London
she's undertaken several research
studies including the South London child
development study which examined the
effects that the mother's adverse
experiences have had on their offspring
from childhood into young adulthood
Susan take it away
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen parenting does
matter and maybe more than you think and
this is why I'm opposing the motion we
all have two biological parents most of
you will know who they are some may not
I invite you to hold your parents or
those who cared for you as a child in
mind ask yourself this question have
your parents and the way that you were
brought up whether for good or ill had
an influence on your life and who you
are today Robert would say not really in
fact he has said that if you had been
adopted out of the family gone to a
different school held a different job
you would essentially be the same person
as you are today I think this is not
true I believe that parenting does
matter
and what is more it matters even before
you are born evidence based on 30 years
of research shows that our experience in
the womb has profound implications for
our well-being from conception to death
exposure to maternal depression as a
fetus as an impact on the well-being of
the infant child teenager and young
adult Robert has described how genetic
research has exploded over the last
decade this new knowledge has emboldened
him to say that parenting doesn't matter
but there's also been an explosion of
research in neuroscience biochemistry
psychology and psychoanalysis and this
emboldened me to say that parenting does
matter
in order to show you how important
parenting is during the nine months of
pregnancy I will describe how rapidly
the human fetal brain develops at four
weeks the brain of the embryo is not
much bigger than a grain of salt
and at seven weeks it barely measures
six millimeters but fast forward to the
final trimester and the developing
baby's brain has increased in size by
260 percent to 341 cubic centimeters a
third of the size of the adult brain and
this does not happen on its own the
developing fetus collaborates with a
mother on a mutual construction project
the fetus needs the mother to provide an
environment that's healthy and this does
not just mean good nutrition the fetus
also shares the mother's State of Mind a
mother-to-be may be under stress because
of a demanding job conflicts in a
relationship or a lack of resources
stress is not helpful for the fetus
although a little stress may be fine we
have shown that stress can lead to
cortisol the stress hormone crossing the
placenta and reaching the fetus
affecting the development of the brain
David Barker was the first to show that
the environment of the womb plays a
powerful role in influencing our later
susceptibility to certain chronic
diseases and how long we live studies
have shown that if you stress an animal
during pregnancy this will have
long-term effects but we didn't know if
this happened in humans because it's
unethical to stress a human fetus we
have to wait for natural or man-made
disasters to occur changes brought about
by undernutrition during gestation
were found in the children of pregnant
women exposed to the Dutch famine at the
end of World War two these children were
more susceptible to diabetes obesity and
cardiovascular disease the finding that
certain circumstances in life cause can
cause genes to be turned off or turned
on is what we call epigenetics this is
something that Robert has let go and yet
it is of fundamental importance when we
think about how parenting matters or
doesn't matter
my cremini one of the world's leading
epigenetic cysts discovered the
importance of maternal care in modifying
the expression of genes that regulate
the stress response in other words
mothering changes gene expression you
desert with pregnant survivors of 9/11
also showed that traumatic experiences
can leave epigenetic marks that alter
the stress response in the offspring the
children of women who were raped by the
rebels and then forced to kill while
pregnant in northern Uganda showed
psychosomatic symptoms in the form of
fainting spells as if they were dead my
own work in South London has shown that
children exposed to the mothers
depression while in the womb as opposed
to after birth or more prone to having
emotional and conduct problems
throughout their lives at 25 they had
higher c-reactive protein levels in the
blood inflammatory markers indicative of
both physical and mental ill health we
also found that a mother's history of
mental illness or her polygenic score
for mental illness did not predict the
offsprings problems as might be expected
according to Robert's thesis it was the
children's exposure to maternal stress
in the
boom that predicted them prenatal like
life is a time of enormous neurological
change and the nervous system is
particularly vulnerable to programming
influences this is where the care of
another human being comes in and you
will hear from Annie how parental care
continues to sculpt further brain
development until the child turned young
adult can care for himself let me take
you back to your own childhood not many
of us will remember our experiences in
our mother's womb but what do you
remember about your childhood no doubt
we will all have some good and some bad
memories but most of them will be about
the way we were parented rather than
about our genetic genetic makeup how
many of us can genuinely say that we've
not suffered an adverse childhood
experience a show of hands usually shows
that the majority of us will have
suffered from at least one Robert
conveniently dismisses those with these
experiences as outliers but if he does
then he's not in the real world this is
about all of us the effects of traumatic
experiences lasts whether or not they
are emotional in the form of bullying or
antipathy or physical or sexual or in
the forms of neglect or in the form of
having someone in the family with a
mental illness domestic violence
substance abuse divorce our experiences
as children will affect us when we are
pregnant and have an effect on the
unborn child and we come up that
father's off the hook here either recent
studies have shown that paternal
environmental and nutritional factors
also affect the phenotype of the
offspring by altering its genome I have
shown that a mother's history of adverse
childhood
aneesa's predicts problems in the next
generation by antenatal depression very
recent studies are showing that
epigenetic markers can be transmitted
through two generations the children's
children in the Dutch hunger famine have
the same low birth weight despite their
mothers normal food and calorie intake
but as Annie will tell you the good news
is that positive experiences in early
life of the newborn can build resilience
and protect him or her from the effects
of trauma let me end by asking another
question what do we want for ourselves
and for our children most of us would
say that we want to be happy and that we
want our children and grandchildren to
be happy perhaps we should learn from
the toda tribal tribal group in southern
India their fundamental principle is
that success should be judged not by
statistics or the amount of money earned
but by the quality of human character I
would not be standing here today based
on my polygenic score for debating it is
the care that I've received from my
parents the way that my father got me as
the shy little girl to practice speaking
aloud in order that I could take part in
a play and from my three children yes
parenting can go in both directions how
else would I have learnt to be a risk
taker I certainly did not get that from
my parents as my children can testify it
is my experience of being parented and
of being a parent this made a difference
and showed me that
parenting does matter and does make a
difference I urge you to vote against
the motion
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's great well I imagine many people
are feeling firmly back on the hook for
me it's extremely close different data
sets extremely compelling arguments our
next speaker is also speaking for the
motion Stewart Richie is a lecturer in
the social genetic and developmental
psychiatry Center at King's College
London his research focuses on
intelligence and cognitive abilities
using genetics and brain imaging and
other methods to shed light on why some
people are smarter than others
the people in this room presumably
thanks to it good evening thanks very
much for coming along and thanks to
intelligence squirt for inviting me
along tonight um
parenting does matter but it doesn't
matter as much as you think the effects
of parenting have been hugely oversold I
think we still live to some extent in
the shadow of of Sigmund Freud who
dreamed up all these arcane theories of
how even you know seemingly innocuous
acts by the parents could have a really
grave effect on their children's life
outcomes and my favorite example being
he theorized that at least in some cases
children's asthma was caused by them
overhearing their parents having sex and
imitating the heavy breathing that they
heard attacked that's true that's not
made up that's true well it was made up
by Sigmund Freud it wasn't made up by me
and and so despite this kind of
absurdity we still follow Freud in
making that assumption that parenting
matters a great deal just listen to any
celebrity interview on you know discs or
a biography or autobiography of a
notable person you'll see lots of
discussion of parenting and all these
assertions about how their parenting had
had a very long term effect on them and
we to wrists resist the urge to to jump
from anecdotes like that to their
conclusions about how
much parenting matters in general and
this assumption that said that the
differences between people are caused by
differences in their parenting and it's
been called the the nurture assumption
by Judith rich Harris in her book in
1998 it's so pervasive that it even
affects the research of scientists who
should really know better and take for
instance a study just published a couple
of weeks ago in the journal social
science research
The Guardian brought this up in their
headline was growing up in a house full
of books is a major boost to literacy
and numeracy and in the study across
several countries children who did
better at school tended to be from homes
that were that were full of books so
more books better great but there's a
gigantic flaw as Robert was saying in
his speech with this kind of research
not only was this just a correlational
study and a non experimental trial that
randomly assigned children to homes of
different library sizes which probably
wouldn't get past the the old ethics
board but it did miss an extremely
important source of similarity between
parents and children and that is their
genes parents don't just socialize their
children into a love of reading and
learning bright their parents both have
more books at home and tend to have
brighter children and that's because
they have passed on a genetic tendency
the tendencies to be smarter more
inquisitive more academically inclined
and are all really all linked in part to
genetics and indeed the behavior
geneticist Eric Turk Homer has called
this the first law of behavior genetics
that is all human traits are to some
extent heritable and forgetting the
first law when you're doing research is
says it's pretty mortifying and that
study about books in the home didn't
even mention the possibility that
genetics might explain some of the
reason I even did like ctrl-f genetics
on the paper and there was nothing that
there's nothing in there but as I said
this is a very very common mistake in in
in research any study as Robert said
that report
a correlation between some parenting
behavior on the one hand and some child
outcome on the other and that doesn't
take into account the effects of
genetics is for all practical purposes
and useless with only a few exceptions
um and to be completely clear I'm not
saying that the research shows parenting
has no effects at all indeed if you do
the proper studies the ones that can
control for genetics through twin
studies adoption studies and so on and
you do find potential parenting effects
for a few outcomes like educational
attainment and so on and and there are
even some new results I should say that
imply we might be overestimating the
genetic effects on some traits like
education and there's certainly nothing
in this kind of research that supports
anything like genetic determinism or any
of those other scary terms but the broad
conclusion from this kind of research is
is pretty clear within the normal range
of things parents do so outside of
neglect and abuse and so on parenting
traits sorts of pains appearing effects
on traits like intelligence and
personality and so on and disorders like
depression and schizophrenia can be
scientifically described as small to
teeny-tiny and so whereas parenting
might matter somewhat for some of these
outcomes and it doesn't matter anywhere
near as much as people assume and we
don't really even need fancy genetic
behavior genetic studies to to know that
parenting can't be all that important
but there's a common observation from
parents who have multiple children that
each individual child shows very
different behavioral tendencies from a
very early age and that's backed up by
research where siblings don't correlate
unless they're identical twins don't
correlate all that strongly on on on
most outcomes of interest and in fact
was a recent study that asked people to
estimate the extent to which traits like
your eye color your intelligence your
depression levels and so on
we're due to environments or genetics
and and the people who made the most
accurate guesses we're mothers with more
than one child and and so a common
response on hearing this kind of
argument is well okay if what you're
saying is true
and parenting only has small effects and
how maybe I shouldn't bother doing nice
things for my child like care like music
lessons and ballet classes and reading
them at night and so on but that would
be to completely miss the point you
should do all these things not because
the thing you think that they'll build
will shape your child's life outcomes
it's because they're inherently valuable
music and dance and literature are some
of the best and most interesting things
that humans do and getting your child
into them needn't be contingent on
whether you think it'll add a few IQ
points and that's before we get into the
truly eye watering arrayed of parenting
fads and trends that pop up and
disappear baby wearing hock housing
Tiger parenting setback education
elimination communication helicopter
parenting attachment parenting
detachment parenting free-range kids
quality time the family bed movement
baby Mozart baby yoga mindfulness for
kids great growth mindset paleo diets
and even something and I hesitate to
even mention this called orgasmic
childbirth and the reason the reason
that all these the reason that all these
kind of fly-by-night trends and fads are
so short-lived is very simple it's
because they're all pretty much useless
at changing the way children turn out
and these are things which dare I say
middle-class parents get into because
essentially all the basics are covered
their child will probably do fine either
way but what about but what about
children or about children who don't
have the basics covered this is where
parenting really can matter so for the
minority of children who are at high
risk of conduct disorder so you know
problems with disruptive and anti-social
behavior there really is experimental
evidence from meta analyses that shows
the interventions that teach parents to
be more responsive and set limits and so
on and really can have at least a
moderate effect at least in the short
term on their children's behaviors and
and we also know another way of
of improving the outcomes of at-risk
children and that's alleviating poverty
there's good experimental evidence from
economics that reducing poverty via
things like tax credits and cash
transfers and so on and can have a
positive effect on children's outcomes
even in the long term and it's possible
though not certain that that parenting
is actually the mechanism by which that
of those have their effects so to
conclude we substantially overestimate
the importance of parenting and
particularly within the normal range of
parents and behaviors and many people
even scientists who do this for a living
forget about the effects of genetics and
and just to echo what Robert said most
parents should relax and feel less
anxious about the long term effects they
might be having on their child and they
should also feel less guilty about not
engaging in one of those parenting fads
that I listed and have more than likely
zero benefits for how their children
will turn out and that's it we do need
to do more work to examine how parenting
might affect kids who are at high
genetic or environmental risk for
psychiatric or behavioral problems so as
Steven Pinker has argued children aren't
just blank slates or lumps of clay that
we can shape and mold in any way we wish
and if we understand that normal range
parenting has at best modest effect we
can focus less on trying to force
children's lives down a particular path
and more on treating them and enjoying
their company as fellow human beings
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Stewart thank you very much and I would
urge anyone who has the choice to choose
free range kids every time it's also
nice to know that control F shortcut I
imagine if you get nothing else from
tonight that's pretty helpful I don't
know about you I feel like a cat chasing
a laser pointer I am being yanked back
and forth extremely persuasive arguments
but I'm sure we will hear more
persuasive arguments from our final
speaker um
and Pleshette Murphy is a therapist and
a parenting counselor she was the
parenting correspondent for ABC TV's
Good Morning America and she was the
host of parenting perspectives with an
Pleshette Murphy on ABC now her books
include the seven state the seven stages
of motherhood loving your life
without losing your mind which is surely
what we're all trying to achieve and she
serves on the board of and was in fact
previously the board president of zero
to three the leading American
organization dedicated to promoting the
well-being of infants and toddlers
[Music]
um thank you sand and good evening sorry
before I begin Stuart your mother would
like you to call her right out of the
bag well one of the disadvantages of
going last is that what you thought you
were going to hear from the proponents
of this motion was not what I heard at
all and in fact having read Roberts book
several times I'll tell you that he's a
little bit of a wolf in sheep's clothing
tonight because a lot of what he is
advocating wasn't aired and maybe it
will be when we debate because as Susan
made clear parenting matters even before
a baby is born but one of the things
that the other side of the house
believes is that you can actually shape
your child's future based on their
apologetic score which didn't come up
the genetics matters so much that
basically they're saying that everything
you do as a parent you can pluck the
child that put them somewhere else isn't
going to really make a difference in who
they become what we believe very
strongly that while genes may provide a
blueprint of who your child will become
the house is built on love and no matter
their polygenic score which maybe we'll
hear more about or their genetic
propensities or something I love to say
there's single nucleotide polymorphisms
children thrive in an environment of
relationships particularly their
attachment with the people who are
likely to love them the most their
parents so we agree that nature versus
nurture is a false dichotomy we all know
that children as Stuart said are not
blobs of clay or blank slates but we
will argue that even if genes account
for 50% of a particular trait
aggressiveness or shyness or sexual
orientation how parents respond to their
highly assertive or socially inhibited
or gay child matters enormous Lee Robert
and Stuart love big numbers believe me
Roberts book is full of really
impressive statistics and what they tout
and actually Robert refer to this is
that genetic studies are reliable and
replicable unlikely and
which is unstable and largely
unpredictable
exactly life is unsystematic
idiosyncratic and serendipitous or maybe
as they say outside the ivory towers of
King's College [ __ ] happens
but when life deals children a
challenging hand we will argue that it
is the loving hands of their parents and
their carers that matters the most and
on a related point Robert asked earlier
well why are children even environmental
siblings that has children who were
adopted and then compared to biological
siblings in the same family so different
if they have the same parents well
having the same parents doesn't mean you
experience the same parenting I'm sure
those of you who have more than one
child will remember that baby number one
if the dummy fell on the floor you
boiled it and sterilized it and by baby
number three or four he was lucky if you
so much as licked it off before you
popped it back in his mouth parental
relationships are not static they
changed and they evolved but they always
matter finally we believe that Robert
believes that the [ __ ] genetic gene emai
be out of the bottle
but that encouraging parents to rely on
polygenic scores or on what they can
learn about their child's genetics
scores in shaping their children's
futures is absurd so let me start with
our central point that DNA may provide
the blueprint but that the house is
built on love how many of you are
parents okay I would say most of the
audience so I want you to imagine a time
when you were engaged with a face with
your baby and some kind of face-to-face
interaction maybe we're feeding her or
bathing him or just plain and your eyes
meet and you gaze into your baby's face
and your baby coos or goals or smiles
and you say oh hello there you're happy
today what are you trying to tell me and
your baby responds by cooing or smiling
or dribbling some peach puree down her
chin this is what we call a serve and
return interaction it's like a tennis
game and it's unbelievably important in
building those neural pathways that
Susan described earlier
and we know this because neuroscientists
can now look at the electrical activity
in the brains of young children when
they're fully awake and interacting with
others and we also know what happens
when young children do not get this kind
of serve and return interaction or
attention or responsiveness babies
raised in environments of stress or
deprivation and they're not outliers
will show far less activity in key areas
of their brain particularly the
prefrontal cortex which is the kind of
air traffic control center of the brain
that's critical to social-emotional
development and learning relationship
build the brain in other ways if you
imagine a time let's say less happy time
when your child's having a meltdown and
Waitrose or screaming from this cot at 3
o'clock in the morning and you respond
when you do that you provide a sense of
security a buffer from stress and you
send the critical message it's okay I'm
here you can trust your environment and
as hundreds of studies have shown
children who are blessed with positive
healthy relationships with their primary
caregivers are better able to read other
people's feelings and able to control
their own they are able to cooperate to
form friendships to experience increased
self-confidence and to learn and this is
not Freudian theory this is very current
research so put simply it is the
experience of knowing and being known by
another person someone who's there
someone who is just crazy about you that
contributes to the social-emotional the
cognitive the moral and even the
physical development of children so
Robert and Stewart can make a very
impressive case for the heritability of
intelligence and school attainment and
also a host of psychological problems
but I want to tell you a story that I'd
love to share with parents who come with
behavioral questions about their kids it
actually comes from the same research
that Robert referred to in terms of that
documentary these are twins who were
separated at birth and race in different
families and the mothers of toddler
girls were interviewed and one of the
mothers said everything's fine but her
eating habits are driving me crazy she
won't eat anything I give her potatoes
and give her all those things talk
love she won't eat anything unless I put
cinnamon on it it's just driving me
crazy the other mother no problem no
complaints oh she eats everything she
said of course I have to put cinnamon on
it so same genes same love of cinnamon
but in one household this genetic
propensity caused a lot of stress a lot
of conflict in the other no big deal
I would argue that matters a lot to how
these children are going to be brought
up or to use an example from Roberts
book and I quote what if you found out
that one of your children has a low
score for educational attainment which
is quite possible regardless of how high
your polygenic score it makes sense to
go with the grain rather than against it
he then advises that you cut your losses
and not waste money on higher education
that doesn't suit them so let's imagine
parents are told when their child is 2
or 3 or 8 that little Rupert is just
never gonna pass as GCSEs why wouldn't
they just shrug their shoulders and say
what's the point of reading them books
in fact why don't we just take them out
of that lovely school and get them some
vocational training fast well I would
argue that whatever these parents are
gonna save on educational fees they're
gonna pay for in Rob and Rupert's
therapy and actually I'm not joking
because labels are limiting their
unhelpful and their hurtful and is
particularly wrong to label children
it's wrong to label anyone based on
apologetic risk score that has very low
level of predictive power if the current
scores can generate and finally the
other of the side of the house asserts
that genetics are not antithetical to
equal opportunity Stuart alluded to this
quite the opposite they say that if we
control for environmental factors such
as privilege and Prejudice genetic
differences will account for more of the
variance in school achievement and
employment well that does sound fair but
according to a recent article in the New
Statesman we are living in a country
where income inequality is the highest
of any European nation the gap between
the very rich and the very poor is the
largest of any industrialized nation in
the world other than the US and if last
time I checked we were heading in the
direction so are we really meant to
believe that socioeconomic status the
health and well-being of parents has no
impact on children what about that
little girl who might have apologetics
core would predispose are the loving
books as Stewart was indicating what is
she supposed to do if her parents can't
afford to buy books or if she's going to
school hungry every day so in summary we
believe that parental love matters
especially in the early years when it
shapes the brain genes matter but even
if they account for 70% of a trait like
intelligence the remaining 30% can't
make 100% of the difference and last
encouraging parents to rely on genetic
data to guide their child-rearing
practices which is what's being
advocated by the other side is ludicrous
because you cannot draw a direct line
from genes to behavior especially for
something as complex as intelligence so
in concluding I would just say rather
than advocating the use of children's
genetic data by parents or educators
why don't we invest in programs that are
proven to give children the best
possible start in life and support their
parents especially those living and
challenging circumstances I urge you to
vote against this motion thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well this is a very exciting moment in
the evening first of all I should say
thank you very much all of you those who
are totally compelling
[Applause]
[Music]
we're at a very exciting moment of
evening because we have the results of
the initial vote you voted when you came
in and what's lovely is that Roberts do
have some work to do
because for the motion was 17% to the
start against the motion was 66% of the
start so even if you convert the 17%
undecided you still don't have enough
people so you're gonna have to drag some
people who really believe that parenting
is important and persuade them that it's
not which is love me
you're the the kind of terrifying wave
of hands that went up makes me very very
keen to get to your questions we we
would like very very quick rebuttals if
you don't mind but if you could really
limit it to a few quick focused remarks
just to rebuttal anything that you you
you want to get to and I'm going to give
you the opportunity and then we will
throw it open to your interrogation okay
thanks well there's plenty to say but um
I guess I would point to a couple of
problems that we were having in the in
in the scientific literature recently
that I think explain quite a lot of the
issues that that certainly that you
raised about epigenetics and so on and
we're in the middle of right now in in
in science what's been called the
replication crisis where there are many
many studies that are published with
tiny samples with incompetent statistics
with with some some fraudulent some
biased and named in many ways it has
been shown very very very clearly and
unfortunately the world of human
transgenerational epigenetic inheritance
is one of those areas that has an awful
lot of very small very inconsistent very
biased studies and there's a great
article online by by the biologists the
geneticist kevin mitchell that shows
that the critiques a lot of these
studies and shows that really we can't
we're not at the point right now where
we can conclude anything about
transgenerational epigenetic inheritance
in humans now it definitely does happen
in plants and i believe it happens in
worms as well but but but the evidence
in humans is extremely
and and so um stacking that kind of
stuff up the epigenetic stuff up against
a hundred years of really solid behavior
genetic evidence um it's really weak ant
you know to say Oh genetic scores have a
small effect and so on epigenetic
studies are not talking about massive
effects either oh can I can I cut you
off there I know we're gonna get more
from you
Robert dude but I'm just I'm keen to get
to the question so do you want to add a
couple of things well I don't there was
a lot of agreement in a way a having
we're all for love having kids have a
good time you know enjoying their
childhood that's sort of my message too
but I think that will happen better if
we recognize and respect the individual
differences you mentioned having more
than one child is a great saying that
parents are environmentalists until they
have more than one child because after
the fact you can explain anything about
why your daughter's shy for example but
then when the second one is different
because shyness is one of the more
heritable traits in infancy you say I
didn't do that you begin to recognize
that they're very different so that
that's one issue and the other issue is
Annie was going on about the
polytechnics course you notice I didn't
mention that that's the second half of
my book and I thought in ten minutes I
would focus on the first half which is
about the basic twin and adoption
research that shows the importance of
genetic influence but it is very
exciting that the DNA revolution is
beginning to find some of the DNA
differences that account for
heritability but you shouldn't really
turn that around to say oh you're only
explaining a tiny percent of variance
with these polygenic scores I think the
point for us about parents making a
difference or not has to do with those
twin and adoption studies that have
collected data over a century showing
that genetics accounts for about half of
the difference which means the
differences but half of the differences
are environmental but it's not those
shared family environmentally call
nurture and include parenting Thank You
Susan are you happy to offer your
rebuttal yes thank you I want to say
that I am a clinician and as a clinician
I have seen many many people
who have suffered from mental ill-health
and I know and I'm working with mothers
in the postpartum and in pregnancy I
want to give one message that these are
not outliers and although we talk about
adverse childhood experiences actually I
think if I asked you to raise your hands
and I gave you the list which I won't do
but you can find it online I think that
as I said before most people will say
that they have suffered at least one the
we are not outliers I'm not an outlier
and working with women clinically has
shown me that we actually do need to
support them and we can't leave it to
their genetics and if I have one message
to give to the government it's that we
recognize the importance of the
pregnancy period and that we give
mothers and fathers maternity and
paternity leave in pregnancy as well as
postpartum Thank You Susan and
[Applause]
I you know I guess I would just say that
the idea that you're not saying that
genes are deterministic is blyde by the
title of the book if DNA is a blueprint
it's then you know you're not going to
don't have a blueprint for a house and
then end up with a boat the implication
is that genes do make us who we are
that's why that's basically the message
of your book and I think that what we
really have to keep in mind is that as
you showed on that graph that and I'm
not a geneticist but you know what I did
learn from your book is that when we
talk about heritability we're talking
about populations we're describing
populations and differences within
populations is that right so we're not
really talking about individuals but
parenting we don't parent variables we
parent people and there's just so much I
of course agree with you that we
shouldn't force children to be something
they aren't but actually saying that
there's a 70% you know you can look at
their intelligence scores and it's a
point 7 that they're not let's say gonna
be as clever as you'd like and then
actually labeling them not so clever is
really bad parenting and is going to
have a very negative effect on children
so that that's the difference yes
working with what's good about them is
great but I think it's naive to think
that being labeled in a family as the
not so clever one is not going to have a
really bad outcome for children perfect
thank you
so for me at least it's boiling down to
do I want the stress-free life of
someone who's been relegated to the role
of chauffeur security yard and chef or
am I prepared to sign up to the
overwhelming responsibility that what I
do day-to-day might actually have some
serious and profound consequences for my
son the most important bit is your
questions I have loads of questions but
we're going to throw it open to the
floor um should have there we go
can we get when lovely can we get number
two here no you're perfect
this is you're the person I want thank
you that's good um I just find it
interesting that both Joyce and Robert
both ended their presentations by saying
we should just enjoy our children and
not trying interfere with you know
putting on piano lessons and everything
else so my question is I think just what
I'm just touched on is what happens when
you do interfere and you try and box
them into something that they don't want
to do
does that not have a negative effect on
them and to say that it's it's either
nature or nurture it's genetics or its
environmental surely there are some
children for whom some can pass it off
in later life and say I never you know
they can make it light of the piano
lessons they didn't enjoy but for those
other children who felt they were a
failure and they were forced to do
something they really didn't like
doesn't doesn't that parenting have a
negative effect on them perhaps for the
rest of their lives
fantastic question thank you very much
we've taken them in batches of three
number one over here I I find I wonder
where though I share a sense of a moral
vacuum with a with the proposal here in
that if parents are persuaded that their
efforts are not going to be greatly
significant they will be discouraged in
what is a very difficult and demanding
responsibility I have in mind the work
of a Richard Witt Whitefield
Birmingham into brain chemistry of
neonates and the fact that their brain
chemistry will show whether they have
accept
you know part of their nurture emotional
warmth and children who do not
experience need an emotional warmth in
the first year of their lives find it
very difficult to express emotional
warmth later on that's nurture for me at
work
thank you very much the question is the
moral vacuum are we discouraging parents
and third question number four they're
looking at the question from two similar
point of views is a ethically and post
conception we don't really have a
control on the genes so shouldn't we
worry about parenting which is a bit
once we've chosen our mate or shock
board genetic material we can't control
the genetics yet so let's just keep
doing the parenting lovely thank you
okay so we've got a question about what
happens when you do interfere is active
parenting doing some harm I think you'd
like to respond to that question for
everyone are we creating a moral vacuum
are we even by raising this question are
we making people care less and maybe
harming children and another question
about the ethics pre-and ability to
interfere in the genes um Robert Stewart
can I start with you so I I just wanted
to the the question there about the the
brain chemistry and so on I think that
research does suffer from the same
problems as the epigenetic stuff I have
I'm extremely skeptical of that kind of
research and and it really is based on
on very very flimsy evidence and we're
sort of noticing that in science now and
I certainly didn't argue that we just
shouldn't do piano lessons and so on in
fact I argue that we should it's just
that we shouldn't expect them to be
improving our children's intelligence
sort of personality or whatever Amster
be I certainly think that there there
can be in some cases negative effects
but I think you would have to show that
right you would have to show me some
evidence that am not liking piano
lessons turns people into or a different
person and then the otherwise would have
been and I don't think there is any such
evidence and shouldn't we worry about
parenting because we can't or
the genes well we're seeing the effects
of parenting are are much much smaller
than people than people think the
outside environment things like
alleviating poverty in society is what
we should be looking at not trying to
tell people to do free range parenting
or all the other lists of ridiculous
things I that I mentioned and the point
that we're making is not genes matter so
the environment you know we don't even
care about the environment it's that we
need to find the things in the
environment that do matter and parenting
doesn't really seem to be one of them
Susan and anchors I said to you well I
mean obviously we're all in favor of
alleviating poverty for one of the
reason one of the reasons is because a
lot of children are living in poverty
and I think that their parents are you
know putting up with situations as Susan
says the Aces research or the idea that
you can just kind of consider abuse or
neglect or poverty or some of the other
socio-economic issues that families face
as outliers that's not what we're
considering here in the research I think
it's just you know I think that this is
really misleading because I actually
don't think that that's what you've been
saying you said several times if you of
these people aren't outliers and so on
do you mean that in a statistical sense
do you mean that do you mean that do you
mean the people who are at the end of
the distribution are not are not
outliers because they are right they are
right maybe we could show her hat have a
show of hands of the number of people
who feel that they have been bullied at
some point in their life and what does
that show it's it's one of the adverse
childhood experiences yeah well but you
can ask people about all sorts of things
the point is that the only the things
that people the things that people care
about in terms of there's adverse
experiences that have effect are when
you have scores of a dozen points on
that scale right not where it's an
arbitrary point at which you draw the
way of course but but it's not that
everyone has one the whole point is
people differ in their experiences and
their their personalities and their and
so on but but but it's it's way old
olds up to the point that it has an
effect and what we're seeing is those
are people who are the outliers that's
something we need to think about
obviously but but to say anyone who has
any experience that's been negative at
all in their life is you know that
that's that's apparently disproves the
effect of genetics or something does it
not help us that we have a parent who
can support us when we come home from
school and been bullied surely that
parenting is important to help us
through these difficult circumstances
you'd have to show me the evidence of
that can I cut the comical on Robert
here I would just say that if 90% of the
people here had an adverse experience it
goes against your argument in a way
because these are obviously
well-adjusted people that's how you sell
a lot of books okay can we get three
more questions please number one I'd
like to ask the against team by what
mechanism do you think post birth
parenting predominantly works is it
through molding neural plasticity or is
it by influencing gene expression and
for the pro team I'd like to know have
you either if you try to account for
epigenetics in any way and the influence
of the microbiome and the immune system
on gene expression Oh lovely meaty
questions thank you number three
hi-yah question for the team as well but
actually to everyone I think one of the
things she has been a lot of agreement
on is really quite a romantic idea that
we all have these abilities within us
waiting to be unleashed and we shouldn't
be boxing children in I think as someone
said so I think you know Robert you
finished by saying we we need to find
out what children like to do and
encourage them to do that
Stewart you said you know you need to
find out the things you're interested in
and and push down that path and
similarly I think and you said we
shouldn't force people to be something
they're not so you've all agreed on this
idea that we have this intrinsic thing
with inner cities what we are but I just
want to explore that a bit more to a
certain extent I agree I totally accept
that you know maybe with 100-meter
sprint a large part of your ability to
sprint 100 meters is going to be genetic
but what about interests and interests
for me are just as important if not more
important than ability if I just take
you know much I'm not a trivial example
but I really love cricket and football
if I've been adopted my American parents
have a brilliant no I wouldn't love
cricket and football because it's not on
the telly
you know people that they don't even my
age we're not watching it as much you
can tell that's very trivial that
doesn't matter I just can I ask you to
the question is what about interests
interests really matter in life and
surely our parents must determine our
interests it's why not put the
interesting it's not so bad to put some
interesting genetic module within us
they're gonna get to it they'll get to
it thank you thank you very much
number two thank you I have two adopted
children and both of them received no
love no attention from in the womb to
until there were two but I think you can
expand this to other children
unfortunately lots of children do not
receive love and attention in the first
two years of their life so my question
for the panel is are they doomed because
they never got the nurturing love they
needed to get at the beginning or if I
got lucky with the lottery of their
biological children I'm just fine and I
can relax because if they got good
parents they're gonna be superstars
[Music]
[Applause]
an amazing range of questions there from
the deeply personal this is this is
usually what there's a lot of stake to
the very specific scientific mechanisms
and the the intuitive role of what our
parents do for us
can I this time start with Susan and
Anna well actually two of us two really
important questions this issue of sort
of neural molding and how much after the
baby is born I mean the brain is
incredibly plastic and the first few
years of life so I would say to you that
actually what you are doing with the
babies no matter what kinds of early
experiences they had will make a huge
difference we see this from things like
the Romanian orphan studies and these
are controlled studies where the
children who were put into foster care
after they had been institutionalized
for a few years were almost
indistinguishable from children who had
grown up in homes that had not been
adopted these are the kids who were
institutionalized at they'll you know
200,000 of them were in institutions in
Romania so there's lots of evidence that
shows that what you do as a parent makes
a big difference and I would say that
that's a response to your question
there's no question and I'm sure Robert
and Stewart would agree that there's
plenty of evidence that what we do as
parents makes a huge difference that's
really our point I would say that the
interest question is very important I
think you know how you are raised what
God you worship doesn't that have an
effect on who we are that has nothing to
do with genes and there are lots of
other things that make us who we are and
you know that that have nothing again to
do with our genetic propensity but
actually the issue of forcing children
to do things this is not good parenting
and we would all agree that we don't
want to force children into doing things
that they don't want to do well maybe
but the whole interest thing is that is
is is really important and as pet as as
parents we should look at our children
and work with them in that relationship
to determine what is in their best
interests
and work together in that relationship
so I feel like we're giving a very
strong case that there is a sort of
intuitive experience or belief that from
from what sports we play to to where we
were we where we worship is deeply
shaped by our parents and those are
things that we feel quite profoundly
about can you can you respond to some of
those issues and and maybe also there's
a scientific question I'd like to first
speak to the Romanian study because
that's done by my colleague professor
Michael Rutter and that is way out of
the normal range of deprivation I mean
those kids weren't even touched by
people they were left alone you know in
soiled diapers it's the worst sort I
mean you'd be arrested if you did that
as a parent but the point that he's made
after all these years is those kids have
turned out pretty well despite that
horrendous first two years of life so it
seems to me it goes against your
argument but no but that's because of
the the ones who've done pretty well are
the ones who were given you know
opportunities to be moved into foster
care are not the ones who stayed in the
institutions and in fact the input the
point is that because they were you know
this was a natural experiment unformed
thank God we don't have too many of
those but the indications were that
these children because they weren't
loved they were fed many of them were
fed and clothed but what was missing was
love and it caused major problems on all
levels physical emotional psychological
and it does go against the idea though
of the like the sensitive the very
sensitive period in the first few years
of life that everyone talks about if
that's the case right why does it go
against well because as Robert said if
these kids turned out they were not
adopted out who's against the no they
were not okay unfortunately if it was
after a certain period of time they
never recovered well we could probably
disagree yeah
and can I can I just mention the
epigenetics and microbiome thing um
there are fads and parenting and there
are fines in science as well and and
those two are current fads in science I
think it's completely fine to look into
that stuff but it's really important but
we do not have anything like the level
of clear data on on epigenetics
microbiome and all that stuff than we do
on on behavior genetics then the
question was then what is is there a
mechanism of post birth parenting you're
saying no it's not that it's not I'm
saying no it's them saying we don't know
yet and we shouldn't be afraid to say in
some scientific questions we don't know
I also don't think we should overstate
the case and hype up the case for things
like epigenetics because we really don't
know the answer yet and there's an awful
lot of hype in science and we need to
and we need to we need to we need to
stop making things up
can we get can we get two more we've got
time for I think two let's get three
more questions go on in number one
Stewart you mentioned about the studies
of children with conduct problems and
you'd said obviously there is some
evidence there that kind of supports
that that makes a difference
intervention so that would be working
with parents teaching them to do things
like one two one time
Priya's curtain implies consequences and
binder eases what things that people
traditionally think of as good parenting
and I was just wondering what your
thoughts were regarding that number
three hello
I'm sure I'm not the first to observe
that the two speakers for the motion a
male and the two speakers against
emotion a female and I'm just wondering
how much of this is to do the fact that
and this is a gross generalization but
traditionally women or mothers tend my
very careful that tend to be the more
nurturing parenting roles
I think that's I think you phrased that
question very elegantly and if you
hadn't asked it I would have done thank
you and number four I have a question I
have a question for the four team how do
they know that that data's not
completely biased based on the fact that
people had to volunteer to be a part of
these Twin Cities
doesn't this predetermine the data and
also I've got a point on outliers is
that the outliers are wherever you are
in the statistical data is outliers if
you want to count them as outliers so as
they're interested in not normal
children there's an outliers Oh lovely
thank you very much these are fantastic
questions these are this is a difficult
topic very sensitive for many people and
I'm very grateful to all our speakers
for handling it so sensitively Robin
Stuart can you start maybe respond to
that they're working with working with
parents the one-to-one things um but but
gender and agenda and outliers seems to
me I'm particularly curious about the
gender one we seem to have genes that
make us believe that we matter as
parents even if we even if we don't so I
wonder if you could respond first of all
to which question now welter or if you
gather up whichever whichever bits of
response you want to offer us well we
tried hard to improve the gender balance
at least it is two males and two females
and then sand I don't and none of us can
help our gender but you know I'm a
parent I have five kids depending on how
you count so I don't know I mean how
much of the variance is explained by
gender in terms of nurturance and loving
your children I would I would not be
very pleased if someone told me because
I'm a male oh I can't love my children
but do you think maybe men care a little
bit men want to believe that they are
less influential parents than they might
be I feel more - I feel more drawn
towards your but but possibly because
fatherhood is different to motherhood
mm-hmm I don't know it goes beyond the
question of genetics though doesn't it
yeah okay hopefully people can respond
to our points hopefully pick another you
know respond to the points we're making
in terms of you know with a rational
analysis of the scientific point so
we're making rather than whether we're
male or female hopefully we're beyond or
beyond that I think that the the
question about you know the the flaws
and the research and again I am NOT a
geneticist but there's no question it's
not just that their volunteer
volunteered but I would wonder if zan
you know twins are raised very
differently identical twins are raised
very differently in families than
dizygotic twins they're often treated
like they're dressed the same they have
similar friends so there's flaws in the
research on that basis you can't really
compare them to families where they're
not when they're not identical twins
that's one thing the other thing is that
I mean I made a note here that most of
the genetic research is done on
so-called weird populations Western
white educated industrialized rich and
democratic that to me also excused the
data yeah well I just might say that I
agree with the second point disagree
with the first so the first point has
been explicitly tested you can and there
are cases of mistaken identity when some
parents think that they're identical
twins are actually fraternal twins and
vice versa and you still and you still
well you deliberately you you you get
those feelings you experiment and you
find that once you're controlling for
that you basically find the same effects
this would say so that's not really a
problem
and the weird thing the way educated
industrialized stuff completely agreed
but that's a problem that we have across
all psychological research not just not
just in in twins so so it's a problem
that we have in psychological research
including the stuff that's been brought
up by the other side of the debate
maybe I should just answer that but my
own research has actually taken a
cross-section of well it's a long
attitudinal study but it's children
brought up in the born women pregnant in
to inner-city GP surgeries and I don't
think that there's anything about those
as outliers when you were born in
Lambeth or in Thamesmead but maybe you
think those are I don't think that I
think it's not necessarily the rote
layers but I think that's our study
that's genetically confounded right so
we don't we can't if we find the
correlation between a parenting behavior
and a child outcome it's genetically
confirmed so we can't actually tell
whether it was due to parenting or
genetics so that's the problem with that
kind of study we do have time for a
couple more questions
although the microphones that mic
friends are still out can we grab a
couple more number one have you got a
question ready perfect thank you um one
thing that'd be helpful is if you guys
could each kind of tell us what you
define as parenting because it seems
like the fore side is saying parenting
is don't contort yourself with you know
all these extra things like the latest
fad parenting whereas the again side is
saying don't neglect your children and I
think everybody might agree with that
you're just coming it'd be helpful to
say what are you talking about when
you're saying parenting matters and it
doesn't matter
thank you very much lovely
and number three hi can I start by
saying I'm I'm actually genuinely
surprised how much I think you were both
arguing the same but I won't ramble
don't worry my question is a lot of my
family and friends who are well-read not
me often mention the issue of peers in
this discussion which I'm surprised
hasn't come up in this conversation and
from what I've heard I've heard this
general bantering of 50% genetics 25%
parenting 25% peers what do you guys
have to say about the influence of peers
fantastic is there a third question over
here thank you I had a question for and
Pleshette Murphy you said and I think
I'm quitting what we do as parents makes
a huge difference if that's the case how
do you account for these research
findings from these twin and adoption
studies we've heard quite a lot about
this evening if it's true that what we
do as parents makes a huge difference
had you account for the fact that
siblings raised in the same household
are as different as siblings raised in
different households you said it's
because when we parent even siblings in
the same household would treat the
siblings slightly differently yes that's
probably true but we can't possibly
treat them as differently as an entirely
different set of parents would treat two
siblings separated at birth so how do
you account for the fact that not only
to sibs brought up separately eras
different to each other as to sibs
raised together but more importantly in
neither view of addressed this how do
you account for the research findings of
all these twins that have been brought
up separately separated at birth and
brought up by different families they
turn out to be it turns out almost
identical in spite of being raised
differently if parenting makes such a
big difference which you seem to think
and that's your side of the argument how
do you account for these research going
times you're gonna get that it's good I
tell you what for those of you that
think this is a false dichotomy sitting
in my chair I can feel the heat coming
off each side it is not some it is not
that at all so first of all defining
parenting I'd love to hear from everyone
on that and then talk about peers and
finally
come to your specific challenge there
can we start with you two defining
parenting well I've studied parenting in
many different ways observational
studies videotaped interactions between
children so I've used all the methods to
study parenting that anyone has used
I've had large-scale studies with
developmental psychologists etc so I'm
defining parenting in terms of the
measures that people are using there's
two major factors you know it's a warmth
dimension and a control discipline sort
of factor so we're just using measures
that other people use and call parenting
so in terms of peers oh sorry did you
want to well I'd like just to add that
there is no word in the English well
there is now but the word parenting
doesn't exist in fact there isn't a verb
to parent if you look back in the
English in the English dictionary in the
past and actually it rather negates the
meaning of a parent who is actually a
man or a woman in an undeniable and
relationship with a child by reason of a
biological fact and I think that I
personally would want to call that
parental care and not parenting I often
wonder why we don't blame the children
more and talk about offspring we're all
here worrying about this what are they
doing what are they thinking about are
they having their own debates that's a
lovely definition thank you can you talk
I will I will call back back and forth
can you talk about peers yeah I think
yeah you know this great topic peers
it's interesting how much we focused on
the family but if the environmental
influences are those that make kids in a
family different then as Judith mr.
Harris said a long time ago why aren't
we studying things outside the family
beginning with peers but this happens to
be a debate on parenting it's important
I think it's important to note that just
to say again if it wasn't clear that the
environment we're talking about it's not
just parenting right there's there's
what we call the shared environment so
what makes
in the same family similar to each other
and what we call the non-shared
environment so what makes children
different and nobody here denies any
large effects of the the non-shared
environment the non zero varmint is
through whatever reasons and and some
people think it's idiosyncratic and sort
of random and some people think there
are factors in there there is this big
environmental effect so so nothing's
nothing's you know even close to a
hundred percent of genes even if
parenting is only having a very small
effect and can you talk about peers and
then talk very specifically about how
you how you would rebuttal deal with the
data that roberts you had presented well
i mean i think that one of the things
that first of all somebody said we're
not really at odds it's quite the month
way that maybe this was advertised and i
think that's true because i think a lot
of what is in the book has not been
aired here and i i think that you know
one of the things that's not been said
is that basically i'm understanding that
the robert and stewart believe that
there are lots of psychological traits
and intelligence issues and school
attainment that can be explained by
genes not by parenting and that's where
we differ that's why i wanted to be here
today because I care very much and I do
think that there is such a thing as good
enough parenting I do think that of
course it's culturally relative because
I think what we consider a good parent
in this culture may be very different
than in others but you know my answer to
what you know what do we mean and what
do I feel is good enough parenting is
parenting that recognizes that children
need love but they also need limits that
you know that parents who are there
they're responsive they're empathic
there are lots of variables and robert
has done some wonderful work on studying
what good parenting looks like SS sues
and I don't know about Stewart but maybe
you have to
and the the last the last question was
specifically about that you know that
there does seem to be and maybe it's
it's literally that I'm a little bit
familiar with just cuz I'm a twin I hear
it a lot that there are these examples
and datasets that really seem to suggest
that raised in wildly different
environments individuals can turn out
very very similar how do you how do you
account for that or what how do you
respond to that well I mean actually I
really feel I should defer to Robert on
this because in fact one of the things
he started off by saying is that 50% of
our genes have you know are contributed
by our parents but you know the other
50% is how we're parenthood or how we
have or what our friendships are like or
in Roberts case you had somebody as a
professor as I remember in your story
who plucked you who basically made you
write that application for a graduate
school that would not you know you might
not have been here if it hadn't been for
certain people and this is true
particularly for children who grow up in
hard situations where there's often one
person a coach or a priest or a friend
or a neighbor if the parents aren't
there for them who makes a huge
difference and I would agree with
whoever asked the question that we can't
just look at parents in terms of twin
studies I mean I think that first of all
the number of situations like that
documentary showed are very rare because
it's not done anymore we don't separate
identical twins and have them adopted of
you know in other families but when we
do look at the twin studies again what
we're seeing and this is probably why
we're not disagreeing very much is that
it is both I mean we're not saying that
you're a blob of clay and that the only
thing that influences you is you know is
your parenting but in fact the reason
that kids are different in families is
because a they're different when they
arrive and be I would argue that parents
relationships too number one two or
three are very different I mean to
someone's point you know parents raise
their children raise their parents as
much as parents raise their children
Susan you had a comment about men yeah
yes I
[Laughter]
that's arising really in response to the
person over there that said she'd
noticed that there were two women on
this side and two men on this side so I
just wanted to say that well I wondered
whether it was something to do with the
fact that that men feel that their role
as a parent ends at fertilization and I
want to say to you men out there you've
heard the arguments your children need
you more than just your genes and they
need you we need you as mothers and we
need you and you are as important as the
women so please don't feel that we're
ignoring you by just these events are
not called intelligent squared for no
reason I've just been handed a very
pleasing note that says let's skip the
closing statements the questions are so
good so sorry about your closing
statements but since you've since most
of you have voted in the vote is now
being counted we don't need closing
statements we could just enjoy the feast
of soul and flow of reason if the
microphones are still out there does
anyone have any more questions get your
hands up and we can we can draw on them
we've got number two coming in here
number one is that is there somebody
ready to go lovely let's call a number
one hi can you can you tell me how much
you think parenting matters in
percentages from each side thank you
lovely clear clear clear question number
two as as a as a parent to a Rupert and
analyser who Shops at Waitrose
I thought I'd arity yeah I'm brother
verlan and I'm I'm a sport playing rugby
loving academic who went to university
but isn't conscientious but I married
somebody who is conscientious didn't go
to university and doesn't like sport am
I covered on all bases do I have to do
[Applause]
[Music]
that's very nice this is the third
question over here I think we heard a
lot of a strong evidence evidence-based
the argument against but my question for
a prenatal period I just wonder is that
really parenting because I would say
this is part of nature rather than
nurture lovely question thank you very
much okay very quickly teams I want
percentages then I want to know if
you're choosing your partner just get
the opposite person to you does that
solve it we don't need to have the
debate then and a prenatal period
quick quick because then we've got the
answers the vote so quick responses
starting with Robyn's chair okay fifty
percent of the variance is not genetic
it's do the environment but how much of
that is due to specified parental
affects I can come up with a few cases
where it's maybe 10% but on average I'd
say it's less than 5%
you've already ready just a slightly bit
of these things differ across the
lifespan so there are larger parenting
effects earlier and lifespan for
something like intelligence than there
are later
and as Rover said there are some traits
that have larger effects than that so
things like education has a larger
shared environmental effect than than
something like intelligence or or or
height or something like that or or
indeed psychopathology yeah lovely but
we've got 5% do you want to give a
number I'm afraid you're not going to
get a number out of me I think it's the
false dichotomy I go I mean obviously
genetics is important and only it
accounts for a lot but I think that of
course parenting the the epigenetic
effect is affecting the gene so I don't
think that we can quite I can give you a
percentage I don't know can i push you
for number n well yeah I mean I would
save just the opposite I would say that
I would say parenting accounts for
probably huge a percentage or I put it
another way I think it's that 8020 rule
I mean if you know if something can be
explained by ATP
genetic predisposition accounts for 80%
of a particular trait to me the 20% can
make all the difference it's not that
you can't weight it equally in my
opinion in terms of what matters as far
as the quality of a child's life I mean
and I would only say that if you like
the research and it sounds compelling by
Roberts book but don't support the
motion
that's very that's very good solving
partner choice but in either case
whether whichever side you fall off on
part of the choice should you just be
choosing someone wildly different to you
can you talk about that any anything
about partner choice yeah it's an
interesting area of genetic research
actually but on the whole spouses don't
made it so totally as much as people
think but it has some interesting
genetic consequences but on average the
most important thing for parents to
remember is that children are only 50%
chips off the old block and what you
need to recognize is that your children
are different genetically from you and
each child is genetically different from
the other children
prenatal period is that parenting no I
don't think so I don't think it matters
and I don't think it can be called it
can be called parenting in the same way
that things like you know how you set
boundaries and rules and so on and this
is the sort of thing you get in
parenting advice and if one if one of
the strongest things I've mmm I would
argue tonight is that all that stuff
about parenting advice it's probably not
really helping or making much of a
difference there's some good ideas in
there that you might want to try there's
nothing to make a huge difference the
way your kid turns out in terms of their
intelligence and their their personality
and then I'll just chuck in one very
brief point which is that if people are
parenting their children and differently
you know we talk about you know it's not
just that the same parenting occurs to
every child and every child it screams
to the same parenting that completely
undermines all these parenting books
that give you advice on how to treat
your kids right these give general
advice but if you're treating your kids
if every every child individually then
that can put them domains all that way
so it's it's all of it it's all a bit of
a disaster we won't end on that okay
to the person who asked the question
about parenting in the prenatal and in
the prenatal life it goes back to my
question my answer about what is
parenting and if we go to what is a
parent and parental care then this is
about a relationship with your child and
that begins at the moment of conception
and both mother and father are important
can't you see the weird genetic
determinism obviously but but where
environmental determinism too so the
moment of truth what's very nice about
this result before I announce it is that
everyone gets a bit of a wind so
remember I'm in the preview was 17%
against was 66% and don't know was 17%
so in the final vote for was 29% so
you've dragged quite a few people up I
mean you've almost doubled it there
against dropped a little bit but you did
carry the day with 51% and don't know
we've slightly increased the amount of
confusion to 20% which i think is lovely
[Applause]
can I thank you can I thank you all for
staying so late for asking such
brilliant questions and can you once
again please thank our amazing speaker
[Music]
[Applause]